take yourself out of the equation who's
the best running back in the nfl right
now um i'm gonna say christian mccaffrey
yeah you like mccaffrey's game i'm gonna
say he's he's just all around i trained
with him his work ethic is is amazing
he's he's a freak um he can catch the
ball you can run the ball in between
tackles uh outside of tackles you can
pass block you can do it all and yeah i
think that's kind of where the game is
evolving to and or where the game is at
right now right running backs right um i
think you know
after the season you had this year i
would say christian mccaffrey
he whacks poetically about that saquon
barkley going all in with our next guest
christian mccaffrey the newest member of
the 1 000 yard club rushing and
receiving only the third guy in nfl
history to do it what an accomplishment
congratulations christian great seeing
you thanks for including us on your tour
today appreciate it no thank you guys
for having me that was that was a heck
of an intro from you know what i would
say is the best rb in the league so you
would you heard it from yeah
i've seen every clip of his man i think
he's a phenom of an athlete and uh
excited to continue to to watch him play
you know as a as a competitor as a
friend as somebody who i admire his game
so we've heard it from saquon we heard
it earlier today from derek henry yep uh
marshall falk
has has heaped preys on you what's it
like when you see these guys who are
great running backs in their own right
automatically coming back to you as the
guy that they put on the top of the
pedestal right now well it means a lot
um you know i think uh there's such a
huge respect in the running back
community in the league and you saw what
derek henry did in the playoffs um you
know you've seen marshall falk obviously
i've seen every clip of his you know
from from the time i was little and
the coolest thing for me is is hearing
guys like that say that because that's
you know that's exactly how i think of
them you know i like to watch every back
in the league take something from them
and
i think the biggest testament to success
is you know a guy like marshall fox
saying that you know who wasn't great
for just one year or two years but
through the extent of his career was
dominant and um that's what all of us
are reaching to do you know guys like
derek henry and saquon and and myself
um you know and all the other backs
around the league is to to be not just
good for a year or two but to be
generational talents i mean natural
god-given talent but like we waxed
poetically a few times during the year
where we would see pictures of you and
you know just your arms bulging out and
everything i think you know your
talent's there but i think i'm like so
interested what's your what's your
training regimen i mean how does this
start when do we start up the off-season
and start getting after it and kind of
what do we do yeah i think you know
there's always something that i'm doing
um you know i've realized as i've been
in the league the most important thing i
do is is rest and and take care of my
body and i'm very fortunate i have a
good team of about five six people who i
work with constantly on you know diet
nutrition uh maintaining weight gaining
weight losing weight whatever it is
right um you know you know chef you know
guys who are chiropractors uh soft
tissue specialists i have a really good
team you know my trainers are very good
where'd you get these guys if you don't
mind me just buttoning up there and it's
funny you ask because i've you know i've
learned a lot from my dad but i've also
just done my research and and reached
out and uh i've found what works for me
right and it's been a lot of experience
since this started in college i was i've
always been obsessed with uh you know
working out and training all that and
finding exactly what's best for me and i
feel like i have a good formula but the
way that you know the way the league and
training in general is going it's so
it's progressing so fast yeah always
trying to be on top of the next thing
and and what's going to help you you
know elevate your game and stay
consistent right how do you process
christian how do you reconcile a year
where it was so phenomenal for you
individually a historic season but for
the team it was another disappointment
how do you wade through that and make
sense of what 2019 was
yeah i think you just got to learn from
everything you know you got to learn
from the things you did well you got to
learn from the things you didn't do well
and and as a leader on the team you know
i think we're getting such a fresh start
as you've seen you know with with
coaching changes with player changes
with guys retiring and um for us you
know there is no set leader on our team
you know we we need everybody to be
leaders you know we need you know no
matter if you're a rookie if you're you
know an eight-year nine-year guy uh i
think we got to start with with a clean
slate and i think we got the right guys
you know we're we've got a young group
who's hungry uh we got a good mix of
veteran leadership and
um you know i think it's just taking it
day by day not worrying about last
season moving on to the next year and
um you know it is a marathon your career
is a marathon not a sprint and i think
the way you approach that is just
focusing on you know one moment at a
time what was your first thought when
you heard that luke lee had decided to
retire
it was bittersweet you know it's for me
it's it's i i'm a fan you know i know
i'm a friend of his and his teammate and
you know we hang out all the time you
know off the field um but you know when
i'm sitting on the sideline and the
defense is up and there's one guy i'm
watching that's 59 and
he's one of my favorite players i've
ever watched he does it the right way
seeing the preparation he puts in seeing
the way he carries himself uh it's a guy
who who in my opinion is he's the poster
child you know i mean he's superman so
right um it's i'm gonna miss him a lot
but i'm so happy for him he went out on
his own terms that's more than a lot of
people can say and i mean what a career
he's had first ballot hall of famer in
my opinion one of the best to ever play
the game at any position and uh and i
was honored to get three years of him
were you were you shocked i mean it
caught us by surprise did you know this
was coming or i i didn't know i mean i i
wasn't thinking about it uh when he when
he told me i was a little shocked but
you know i told him i was like it's a
this is a sad day for football but it's
a worst day for fish and deer because
i'm sure he went
in this thing he'll be doing that a
whole bunch so i'm happy for him and
he'll be able to you know enjoy the rest
of his time it all dropped like at eight
o'clock at night uh on a week night how
how long in advance did you know because
they did a hell of a job at keeping that
quiet until they pressed the button on
the on the tweet that sent it out to
everyone he called me that day and and
told me and and you could tell he was
emotional uh you know i won't you know
give away too much of the personal
conversation but um
i think he he's he's he's happy you know
i mean he made the right decision that
was for himself no one else is that was
no one else's decision but his and uh
you know that was that was powerful of
him to do that and and to go out on his
own terms he had a million tackles
through eight years you know i mean he's
he's done so much for for the game of
football for the carolinas so i was
really fortunate to be able to get three
years of them you uh let's play uh let's
play who said it right all right let's
have some fun with it
from the year i'm not even sure
you've got to guess i can't remember i
can't remember either well we talked so
much but we got a quote from one of us
you got to guess who is one of you two
one of us said that yeah guess who it
was and it's gonna be news to me he was
the eighth overall pick in the draft he
got no hype he was incredible in college
and i think we just assumed ah it's fine
it's cute in college we've seen this
movie before the guy who's the dominant
college running back who comes to the
nfl and falls off the face of the earth
no he's incredible who said that
he said that
did you say it i don't think so i think
i don't remember saying it i think i
have no recollection of it i think it's
not remember i'm waiting for somebody to
tell me we both think you're great
though both said it somebody wanted to
pay attention and
we coincidentally said it at the exact
same time who said it chris probably
both said it is oh i said all right i
said i didn't i didn't speak like that
that wasn't i know i i know that's
that's on me that was
but it really is amazing to watch how
you when you you get out on the field
with other nfl players and you never
know when a guy comes out of college
because it's a different level of
defense right yeah and for some guys it
that the gap is as big at the nfl level
as it was at the college level when did
you first know and i know everybody's
confident that they're going to be
successful in the nfl but there's got to
be a little doubt until you get out
there when did you first know hey this
is it i'm i've got this this is going to
be okay for me
i i don't know if there was a defining
moment uh where i where i realized i
think you know my rookie year was it was
a great learning year for me uh you know
i came in and jonathan stewart was kind
of the bell cow back of the panthers and
so i got to learn under him for a year
and you know i had some touches here and
there i wasn't a you know the running
back that i wanted to be and i probably
wanted to be the starter but looking
back i think i learned so much and
um i think your first 100 yard game i
think you realize that you could you can
do this
uh i forget when that was but but but
even that i mean i always knew i could
play you know just from practicing
against guys you know i was lucky enough
to practice against luke keikley every
day thomas davis every day and my first
run play was towards julius pepper's
side so uh you know i got to practice
against some of the best to ever do it
and going up against them you know i
realized that hey you know i can play in
this league i can do it for a while
favorite play so far your career like
what's the way so far nfl where you're
just like damn that's my favorite one
that was awesome right there i would say
you know we played jacksonville this
year and uh the flip touchdown that that
uh that i did you know
four yard run first drive of the game
and i think it's just kind of a tone
setter run
um
and you know i don't know i don't know
why it was my favorite but it was so
instinctual i had no idea i was gonna
try to jump over the guy i ended up
flipping yeah landed right on my back
didn't feel very good but
that was a fun game we won which was
awesome yeah you tore it up that game
remember right yeah christian is with us
today on behalf of verizon tell us more
about what you have going on with them
yeah it's really fun so i i've been
doing a few things with them yesterday
got to see this whole the new 5g launch
that they just did and the way for me
that i'm excited from an athlete's
perspective is you know watching film
and you know watching film of me
training and different angles and all
that stuff you can see every single
angle
you can look at it from up top you can
watch games and zoom in on specific
players the technology is is pretty
life-changing and um they're doing a
cool thing as far as you know they're
the verizon initiative which is called
one more sunday uh where they're we're
encouraging people uh you know however
much time you spend watching football
this year uh you spend that same amount
of time giving back to the community
you're giving back to your area whatever
it is so um i'm on board and uh it's a
cool thing that verizon the network i'm
on it i just i'm all i'm all about
verizon you guys are having a lot of
family he's doing everything he can to
get himself some of the sponsorship
money you know what everything he's got
that christian mcavery sponsorship money
baby all right we got a little game that
we've been playing before we let you go
we do a little face mash it's some
teammates uh
probably we have teammates you have to
tell us who it is
roll the first one oh gosh that is that
is a weird style that's me and luke
there you go bingo he's one for one i
don't really see you i mean first off
what can we fix the mouth there what the
heck is going on there all right next
one who do we got interesting let's see
roll it
oh
that's dj moore
you're right on that one yeah i could
see that but i don't know the other one
and
oh can you give me a first letter e
eric reed there you go bingo all right
last one
let's see here that's another one that
looks like a real person like some of
them are so seamless shaq thompson james
bradberry shaq thompson curtis samuel
that's good showing overall that's all
right curtis sorry chris christian
doesn't really know you that well i'm
sorry i don't taste that much anymore he
never calls me or texts me by the way
yeah i don't get the invites god damn
come on
so much change
on the team coaching staff everything
cam newton this is he going to be your
quarterback next year
i have no idea you know not not my
decision i know that uh if he is you
know it's somebody who i've had so much
fun playing with and uh he's a guy that
when i came in my freshman year you know
he called me on draft day you know and
you know as a rookie i'm asking him you
know what you know what do you need for
me what do we need this year let's go
win and he said i just need you to be
you
and uh for me that meant a lot and uh
you know he's the same guy he's
consistent he's a heck of a leader heck
of a teammate so
um and i know when he gets healthy and
and he will because he'll work extremely
hard to do so
he's going to be the weapon that we all
know he can be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports